oi meu nome é bruno eu tenho 10 anos e
hoje vou falar sobre o vício das pessoas
no celular e os impactos que isso causa
da nova geração
vocês podem estar confusos pois é com
dez anos faço parte da nova geração e
vou falar sobre vício das pessoas no
celular impactos na minha própria
geração sim este é um assunto de hoje
para começar gostaria de testar o
público desse a vitória fazendo o
seguinte desafio quem consegue ficar
cinco minutos ou seja o tempo da minha
apresentação sem mexer no celular nem
para ver a hora acharam fácil eu sei que
pode dar coceira e irritação
mas vocês conseguem combinado para que
eu fiz esse desafio para falar sobre a
nova fab a uma fobia é o medo de ficar
sem comunicação através do celular e
outros aparelhos digitais
podemos perceber que hoje estamos
ficando cada vez mais dependente do
celular para viver
além da homofobia existe o fogo que é
identificar desatualizado das notícias
fofocas entre muitos outros assuntos são
aquelas pessoas que não conseguem ficar
longe das redes sociais como twitter
facebook instagram entre outras com
receio de perder algo independente de
sua importância nos próximos dois slides
eu vou mostrar fotos para vocês refletir
sobre como vice um impacto da nova
geração
pensaram hoje em dia tanto as crianças
quanto os adultos preferem mexer no
celular tablet computador do que ler um
livro do que ler o livro praticar um
esporte ou simplesmente conversar mas
muito conectados deixam de dar a devida
atenção aos seus filhos passando um
exemplo ruim a criança que faz com que a
nova geração fique assim cada um no seu
celular sem conversar o que a nova
geração perdeu hoje em dia é mais
difícil de você ver jovens lendo o
almoço em família sem televisão ao
celular ou simplesmente jovens
conversando
para impactar positivamente na nova
geração
você precisa saber ser viciado a mudança
começa por você quer saber se você é
viciado no celular
novos sinais de que você está viciado no
celular
quem quiser responder pode responder tá
bom você checa o celular enquanto está
jantando o celular sempre está onde você
pode ver você sempre está com ele na mão
você atende a qualquer tipo de ligação
você checa mensagens de amigos que estão
ao seu lado você não interage com
ninguém
você não deixa o celular de lado nem
quando está em um compromisso você usa o
celular para preencher falta de assunto
você interrompe a conversa porque eu
preciso checar mensagens e aí vocês são
viciados
agora que já sabe o grau de serviço está
sem idéias de como impactar
positivamente na nova geração
divido minhas idéias com vocês
reveja a forma como você usa o celular
seja um exemplo positivo para seus
filhos e amigos
controle o tempo que você e seus filhos
utilizam o celular e garante o bom uso
desses aparelhos estimula a prática de
esportes leitura conversas e
brincadeiras em almoços jantares de
família e evite o uso do celular
agora divido com vocês minhas
experiências
eu não me acho uma pessoa muito viciada
tem o controle do meu tempo diante do
celular e não uso tanto outros aparelhos
eletrônicos
apesar de gostar muito de jogar
videogame só pode jogar de cestas e
finais de semana
eu pratico esportes como futebol natação
e muay thai
eu leio bastante uma prova disso é a
foto acima
minha prateleira de livros estudo e
brinco
obrigado e essa foi uma apresentação
agora você já pode mexer no celular